[Musik]
landtags willkommenes welt heute mach
ich türkischen reis mit husten
dafür brauche ich
400 gramm hähnchenbrust drei gläser
105 leserjury also feinen nudeln 30 g
butter 50 meter und salz dieses rezept
habe ich mir ausgesucht weil es so
simpel und einfach ist es schmeckt auch
ziemlich gut es gibt schnell und ich
finde das rezept weil meine oma ist
immer für mich gemacht hat und das
versuche ich es einfach mal selber aus
jetzt nehme ich mich wieder reis und
diese schüssel hier
und fühlen heißt
wenn ich jetzt salz dazu ungefähr drei
esslöffel
damit die stärke von rise up
geht und jetzt gebe ich noch kochendes
wasser dazu
das ist jetzt
circa fünf minuten ziehen und solange
berate ich schon meine anderen sachen
vor
jetzt schneide ich das hähnchen im
städtle also ich schneide es jetzt in
würfel sauce auch einfacher zum essen
manche schneiden ist in streifen aber
ich finds auch irgendwie einfacher wenn
man das in würfel schneiden
hier muss man noch vorsichtig sein beim
schneiden man kann da kann man sich
nämlich ein verletzten
ich persönlich finde es auch einfacher
wenn man das fleisch nicht von außen
sondern von innen
das ist eigentlich für seine paprika
mein kampf nicht so gut von außen
schneiden also von der schale aus
sondern vom inneren kann man es halt
eben leichter schneiden m ich gehe jetzt
erstmal kurz händewaschen
[Musik]
ich hab das jetzt fünf minuten ziehen
lassen und man sieht ja auch schon die
stärke und jetzt es auch schon zeit den
reis abzuwaschen
[Musik]
ich hab den kreissitz abgewaschen das
wasser klar war und dann hab s einfach
in diesen messbecher umgefüllt jetzt
gebe ich hier in die pfanne in tops man
rein
und dann noch meine kleinen nudeln
ich lass das jetzt so lange braten bis
sie goldbraun ist und ab und zu auch mal
durch das es nicht anbrennt
bot es wird hier richtig gut
gestern habe ich das gestern war voller
fehlen jetzt jetzt viel besser
mit profi unterstützung kommt kurz ins
bild
kommt
das noch so als nächstes als nächstes zu
richtern den kreis rhein
das ist übrigens türkische reis sehen
bekommt man in jedem fachhandel im
türkischen laden oder
mittlerweile gibt es aber auch heute
kommst normale supermärkte
[Musik]
ist nicht zuletzt
das besondere an dem reis hat das
sensorisch also unbedingt noch
er hat auch einen unterschied in der
deutschen reichs deshalb nicht so
traurig und ich finde da hat mich
wirklich geschmack ja kann man das so
sagen ja oder ja es war uns das meistens
sogar ein bisschen mehr fett drin
stehen arbeite mache ich am ende
renditen
und ich trinke auch immer das war also
das meiste wasser wenn wir es machen
etwas zu oben braucht das trinke ich
immer ist vielleicht mag das wohl dass
es stärke
ja wenn ich mein tennis köchelt mit dem
wasser obendrauf das
trinke ich
gleich noch was arbeiten
ich glaube das geht sogar so oder muss
es noch an warten so ok
sogar bekommst mal kurz in
hilfsschiffes anbrennt
dann macht das mal gern das dann aus
kraft und ich nicht mama
[Musik]
sieht die lage aus
und ich finde mich die mutter rein
es ist auch nicht gefällt
[Musik]
ich brachte in reis jetzt kurz zwei
minuten an und dann lösche ich das mit
dem kochenden masse ab ich weiß nicht
was er machen muss noch gefühl so 1 cm
über dem preis ja
genau wasser angabe gibt es glaube ich
nicht aber
ich sage jetzt einfach mal so ein
zentimeter über dem reis sollte das
wasser schon gegen turbo abi kann's mir
helfen noch mal
das was drin
was sagst du mir stockt oder
aussagen heißt noch nie gemacht
meinem arbeitete mal gemacht aber ich
habe nie den reis gemacht ich habe
einmal bei sally im video geschaut
gehabt
und das war es aber auch aber ich habe
nie nach gemacht
es gibt noch ein bisschen salz setzen
[Musik]
wie die marquise
wie die mama wenn ich mir das auch gerne
mal ich lasse es jetzt nach einem deckel
um daraus 20 minuten köcheln oder
ja
aber da verschaffe ich mir das ab
das wetter
[Musik]
ist brate jetzt das fleisch an dafür
gebe ich erstmal oliven öligen zangl
so jetzt habe ich mein herz an gemacht
weiß himmel verbracht egal jetzt gebe
ich das
münchen rhein
[Musik]
und jetzt warte ich dass etwas an
jetzt habe ich den hut auf mittlerer
stufe des fleisches schon durch ich
lasse noch ein bisschen wurzeln und gäbe
80 milliliter lauwarmes wasser dazu
so
und jetzt stelle ich nochmal auf die
stufe 7
und ich lasse es jetzt kurz noch so 23
minuten aufkochen
[Musik]
fleisch ist fertig obwohl nie ich war
zuletzt noch ein bisschen ab mit paprika
edelsüß
und salz und versorgen
[Musik]
so jetzt probiere ich erst mal das
hinziehen
das war lecker und jetzt guck ich auch
noch mal nach dem preis nicht schon mal
lecker
[Musik]
wir haben gemerkt dass er es auch schon
fertig ist
er sieht zwar noch
zu glänzend aus was aber dass noch im
feld
der sehr viel fett zucker
und
butter
und ich lasse jetzt auch mal ein
bisschen abkühlen
und mache so lange in joghurt
[Musik]
jetzt war ich auch noch den joghurt und
ich habe jetzt naturjoghurt
400 gramm joghurt einer hand petersilie
und ein hand ging und noch etwas salz
und pfeffer ich schicke dann noch die
ganzen zutaten in diesem besser rein
weil ich finde einfach einfacher jetzt
schneide ich sie besser sehen
[Musik]
ich hab jetzt mit profi hilfe das
hinbekommen alles klein zu schnippeln
und jetzt gebe ich das einfach in meinen
einmal rein
[Musik]
so jetzt ruhig das erst mal um
so jetzt möchte ich den ganzen spaß mit
salz und pfeffer
die kaufen 139 ich bekomme nicht mal
taschengeld
danke
jetzt kommt noch dass
ich mag es besser
so und jetzt kann ich noch alles
anrichten
jetzt gehe ich zum reißen eine kleine
schüssel rein
randvoll
jetzt drücke ich den preis noch etwas
unter
ok 123 auf geglückt
das kann die sandburgen bauen
wow
okay das passt so
jetzt gewisses hingezogen
so das geht doch so heißt
nur etwas petersilie
so jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen
jugendtreff
[Musik]
jetzt macht die sache noch bilder und
erkennen die endlich essen
jetzt dürfen zwei freiwillige probieren
auf meiner rechten
pokerabend auf meiner linken al-deen
windows danke
zu sagen es schmeckt
ich denke was schmeckt bestimmt -
gemacht
frank sehr gut ich bin ich auch
machen
finde ich auftritten nachkommt das
rezept findet ihr auch sex - blog.de